there was a time meant simple infections
were deadly but now thanks to the wide
availability of antibiotics this is
merely a relic of the past but actually
us who say was because nowadays we using
antibiotics so much that the bacteria
that causes infections are becoming
resistant and that should really scare
the hell out of all of us if you do not
change your behavior and we know sales
of antibiotics the UN predicts that by
2050 antimicrobial resistance will
become our single biggest killer - must
start to act but where to begin is an
interesting question because we humans
are not the only ones using antibiotics
worldwide 50 to 80 percent of all
antibiotics are used by animals not all
of these are critical for human health
but if you do not get it under control
right now we're looking at a very scary
future for humans and animals alike to
begin let's talk about how we ended up
here the first large-scale use of
antibiotics was an early 50s of the last
century in the restaurant world
prosperity was increasing and people
wanted to eat more animal protein we're
all so sick you can now treat them in
antibiotics so they did not die and kept
growing but soon it was discovered that
it's small and regular amounts of
antibiotics to defeat kept the animals
healthy made them grow faster and cause
them to need less feed so these
antibiotics worked well really well
actually
and with increasing animal production
also antibiotic use skyrocketed
worldwide unfortunately so did
antibiotic resistance the reason your
doctor tells you to finish the entire
bottle of antibiotics is if he's
shortened you doze you don't kill all of
the box and that's the ones that stick
around build up the antibiotic
resistance the same problem with giving
animals small or regular doses of
antibiotics
some bad bugs I matter all of them
spread that across an entire industry
and you can understand that we
accidentally build up a large reservoir
of antibiotic resistant bacteria but I
hate to break it to you the problem
doesn't stop there
you know else takes antibiotics fluffy
okay and we're over your dog that's
ranked even amongst the heaviest users
of all and they use antibiotics that are
much more critical for human health
combine this with how close we live for
the companion animals and you understand
the risk of you picking up yourself
antibiotic resistant bacteria from your
own pet but how do these antibiotic
resistance bacteria and farm animals
affect you let me give you an example
you have actually data on the levels of
antibiotic resistance Salmonella and
pigs in Europe against different type of
antibiotics range from less than a
percent as high up to 60% which means
that in most cases this antibiotic will
not work anymore to kill this Salmonella
and there was a high correlation between
antibiotic resistance Salmonella on the
pig and on the final product rather than
this porkchop spareribs of mincemeat now
luckily typically less than 1% of all
raw meat fish or eggs will contain
salmonella and this only poses a risk
when are treated well still there are
100,000 humans some analysis in the EU
and more than a million cases in the
u.s. in the u.s. leading to 23,000
hospitalization and fawn and 50 people
that each year with antibiotic resistant
someone are on the rise this death toll
is likely to increase but it's not only
about consuming yourself this year more
than a hundred people got infected with
a multi drug-resistant Salmonella of the
feeding pig ears as a treat to the dog
so we really must cut back on antibiotic
use in animal production and luckily
that is starting to happen the EU was
the first
to ban putting antibiotics and low doses
in the feed from 99 on in several steps
the amount of different type of
antibiotics allowed were reduced and in
2006 a complete ban went into place
antibiotics were only allowed when a
veterinarian determined the animal was
sick sounds great right problem solved
no wait not so fast as soon as the
reduction program started it was very
quickly discovered that antibiotics had
been the perfect blanket to cover up a
lot of bad phone practices more and more
animals became sick and it'll be cured
with antibiotics so instead of the total
amount going down it actually increased
surely there was not the way to go but
luckily there was not the end of the
story the whole you're being agriculture
sector started on a journey and I think
is a journey everybody can learn from
this is also the time I personally
entered the scene I joined a large group
being feed compounder a feed compounder
makes a total diet for a farmer two feet
of its animals and often also provides
the advice on how to race the animals in
the best way I was really motivated to
work together with my colleagues
veterinarians and of course the farmers
to figure out how to keep the animals
healthy and antibiotic free now there
are three major things that need to
happen for antibiotic free production
let me walk you to the playbook to start
and it sounds very obvious that our
hygiene is the place to start that a
cleaning of this table and the drinking
water lines making it harder for the
disease to come anus fret across this
table that's all very important but the
part I was firstly most interested in
was better feeding for the animals
better nutrition feeding a well-balanced
diet is important thinking about it this
way when you yourself do not even have
fiber do not feel well part of the food
you consume is not digested by yourself
but fermented in your large intestine by
bacteria so you're feeding those
microbes with part of your diet
initially most young animals were fed
low fiber high starch and protein very
finely grinded highly digestible diets
like be yourself on a diet of Hamburg
Bonz wise waffles with protein bars we
changed this to lower protein higher
fiber coarser type of diets like being
in a dial eight of roll grains salad
with Mito beans this shifted the
bacterial flora in the animal guts to
the more beneficial ones and reduced the
chance that pathogens would flourish you
might be surprised but not only diet
composition also dive structure plays a
role simply affect that the same diet is
coarser will lead to a better developed
digestive tract and does a healthier
animal but the best part was that
farmers started to buy this actually too
unlike some other parts of the world
rest in you being farmers mainly still
make their independent buying decisions
would I buy the feed from and sell their
animals too so what you're actually
selling in the end reflects an actual
local need of these farmers for example
the protein content in piglet diets and
countries that were much more vigilant
reducing antibiotics like for example
Germany and the Netherlands we're
already ten to fifteen percent lower
than in a country like the UK which was
slower to pick this up but like with
better hygiene that nutrition helps but
will not totally prevent you for
becoming sick so Moore's needed and
that's when we turn to the microbial
making the water over the feed more
acidic helps to create an environment
that benefits the more beneficial
bacteria and inhibits pathogens like
fermented food whether it's yoghurt
sauerkraut or salami they all will spoil
less quickly too
now with modern techniques like the ones
based on DNA testing we can see that
there are many more different
microorganisms and this ecosystem which
we call the microbiome is much more
complex turns out there are about eight
times more microorganisms in your gut as
tissue cells in your body and from
animals the impact is no less so if you
want to work without antibiotics in
animal production we have to make the
animals much more robust so that when a
disease strikes the animals are much
more resilient
and this three pronged new tuberoses
approach involving the host nutrition
and the microbiome is the way to do it
now the practice of raising animals on
an antibiotic containing or antibiotic
use provoking diet is a bit cheaper at
farm level but in the end we're talking
about a few percent on consumer level
that's actually quite affordable for the
middle and high-income part of the bowl
population and a very small price to pay
when its own health our loved ones
health is at stake so what do you think
what direction do we take do we allow
antimicrobial resistance to become a
biggest killer at huge financial and a
special personal cost
or do we besides reducing human
antibiotic consumption truly start
embracing antibiotic free animal
production for me the choice is very
obvious but to make this happen you have
to set reduction targets and make sure
that are followed all around the world
because farmers compete with each other
and I had a country level trading bloc
or the global market costs are very
important and also we have to be
realistic farmers need to have the
possibilities to invest more and better
management and better feed in order to
achieve this production and besides
legal limits the market can play a role
by offering antibiotic reduced of
antibiotic free products and with
growing consumer awareness these market
forces will increase in power now
everything I've been talking about seems
to be great for us but what about the
animals now guess what their lives get
better - better health less stress have
your life so now you know we have to
knowledge how to produce meat egg and
milk without or very low amounts of
antibiotics
and allowed you it's a small price to
pay to avoid a future in which bacterial
infections again become our biggest
killer thank you
[Applause]
[Music]